.
TODD, ASHLEY.
TODD:  BROOKE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ASHLEY:  VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS STILL HAS NO PLANS TO
HEAD BACK TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER
BUT SHE IS COMMITTED TO JETTING
OFF TO EUROPE NEXT MONTH.
TODD:  JOE CONCHA, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, HERE TO DISCUSS HER
LACK OF ENGAGEMENT AS THE
MIGRANT CRISIS GROWS BY THE DAY.
LOOKS LIKE CAM MA LA IS WORKING
-- KAMALA IS WORKING ON THE
BUCKET LIST.
REMEMBER THIS.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY PLANS TO
VISIT THE BORDER?
>> WE'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
>> YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> AND I HAVEN'T BEEN TO
EUROPE.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW -- I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE POINT YOU'RE
MAKING.
TODD:  WELL, CONGRATS TO HER FOR
CHECKING EUROPE OFF THERE.
BUT JOE, WILL SHE EVER GO TO THE
ACTUAL BORDER AND BY THE BORDER
I MEAN THE PLACES THAT GRIFF
JENKINS GOES, BILL MELUGIN GOES.
>> OH, YOU MEAN LIKE LA JOLLA
OR DEL-RIO?
YOU'LL SEE THAT THE SAME TIME
YOU SEE THE DETROIT LIONS IN THE
SUPER BOWL WHO PUT UP A GOOD
FIGHT AGAINST THE RAMS YESTERDAY
YESTERDAY.
THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION THAT
IS POLLING IN THE 20s IN TERMS
OF THE HANDLING OF THE BORDER.
KAMALA HARRIS AND JOE BIDEN, AND
THE THE NUMBERS BACK IT UP, IN
TERMS OF THE RECORD NUMBER OF
MIGRANT CROSSINGS THIS YEAR,
THEY HAVE ZERO INTEREST IN
TACKLING THIS ISSUE.
THIS IS THE WORK LIKE YOU'RE
WORKING ADMINISTRATION WHEN
YOU'RE ACTUALLY BARELY WORKING.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS NEVER BEEN TO
A BORDER TOWN.
AND THAT INCLUDES ARIZONA BY THE
WAY WHERE WE'RE SEEING THE
BIGGEST SURGE RIGHT NOW.
JOE BIDEN, YOU APPARENTLY --
APPARENTLY DROVE THROUGH EL PASO
13 YEARS AGO AND THE PRESS
SECRETARY SAID THAT COUNTS AS A
VISIT AND THAT'S INSULTING TO
EVERYONE'S INTELLIGENCE.
YEP, HAVE FUN IN EUROPE BECAUSE
WE HAVE A CRISIS AT THE BORDER,
WE ALSO HAVE A SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS GOING ON WHERE YOU WON'T
SEE THE PRESIDENT OR THE VICE
PRESIDENT OR SECRETARY PETE
BUTTIGIEG VISIT A PORT CITY IN
LOS ANGELES, NEW JERSEY, THE
GULF COAST, SAVANNAH, SO AGAIN,
WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION THAT
IS BEING OUT-WORKED AT THIS
POINT BY PEOPLE TRYING TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS THAT DON'T HAVE
REMOTELY THE AMOUNT OF POWER
THAT THEY DO AT THIS POINT.
ASHLEY:  OKAY.
SO WE HAVE TO GET TO THIS.
OBVIOUSLY PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
FACING SOME FALLING POLL NUMBERS
BUT EVEN SNL IS PICKING UP ON
IT.
LET'S TAKE A WATCH OF THIS AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT IT ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> YOU'RE CNN TOWN HALL WAS
WATCHED BY NO ONE AND YOUR
APPROVAL RATING IS IN THE
DUMPSTER.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
PEOPLE USED TO LIKE ME.
I MISS THE OLD ME.
>> WHERE THE HELL DID THAT GUY
GO?
HEY YO.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
WHO ARE YOU?
>> I'M YOU.
I'M YOU FROM EIGHT YEARS AGO,
MAN.
THE GHOST OF BIDEN PAST.
BOOM.
>> HOW CAN YOU BE ME?
YOU SEEM SO HAPPY, SO CARE FREE,
SO -- WHAT'S THE WORD I'M
LOOKING FOR?
>> LUCID.
ASHLEY:  OTHER THAN HYSTERICAL,
LIKE WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON SNL
EVEN THROWING JABS AT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
>> ASHLEY, I WONDER IF WE USE
THE WORD JABS THERE.
THIS IS AS GENTLE AS A BUTTERFLY
LANDING ON A FEW LIP IN TERMS OF
THEIR -- TULIP IN TERMS OF THEIR
MOCKING OF JOE BIDEN.
IS SHOWS HOW FAR HE HAS FALLEN
IN TERMS OF POLLING.
WE'RE ONLY 10 MONTHS INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S WITH FAVORABLE PRESS
COVERAGE.
I'M SURPRISED THERE WASN'T A
STAFF WALK OUT AFTER DOING A
SKIT THAT JABS AT JOE BIDEN.
DID YOU SEE THE END OF THE SHOW?
I DID SEE THE CLIPS.
AFTER PERFORMING FOR 90 MINUTES
ON STAGE WITHOUT MASKS, THE
FULLY VACCINATED CAST, THEY PUT
THEIR MASKS BACK ON.
TALK ABOUT VIRTUE SIGNALING.
THAT'S SNL AT THIS POINT.
THEY GO AFTER JOE BIDEN, KIND
OF.
BUT IT'S NOT WITH THE VITRIOL
THAT WE SAW WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT PLAYED BY A GUY WHO A
VERY TRAGIC THING HAPPENED ON
THE SET OF RUST WITH ALEC
BALDWIN.
I HATE THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
ONLINE AND A SOCIAL MEDIA ARE
USING THIS TO ATTACK ALEC
BALDWIN.
IT'S A HORRIBLE THING THAT
HAPPENED, A HORRIBLE ACCIDENT,
MISTAKE.
LET'S NOT START ATTACKING PEOPLE
BECAUSE THERE IS A WOMAN THAT
DIED HERE I JUST WANT TO END ON
THAT NOTE.
BY THE WAY, LET'S END ON A HAPPY
NOTE, ACTUALLY.
THIS FOX WEATHER APP, BY THE
WAY, JANICE DEAN, I'M LOOKING AT
MY 48 HOUR WEATHER FORECAST IN
JERSEY, I NEED NOAH'S ARK.
TODD:  LET'S FOCUS ON A HIGH
NOTE.
GIANTS WON.